the president for his part has been
quiet on the subject throughout the day
not so much as a single tweet about the
situation in Iraq but his
administration's reaction to the ongoing
unrest and the threat has spoken loudly
and with unmistakable clarity as soon as
we saw there was a potential for problem
they got in and there was no problem
whatsoever the contrast could not have
been more stark glitz and glitter on the
one hand happy new year
grit and gumption on the other yet there
was still surprising parallels between
the president's New Year's Eve gala and
the deployment of additional US Marines
to the embassy in Baghdad in each
instance a projection of calm amid
simmering unrest half a world away well
I think it's been handled very well the
Marines came in we had some great
warriors come in
do a fantastic job and they were there
instantaneously as soon as we heard this
will not be a Benghazi well there is a
stark difference between the facilities
in Baghdad and Benghazi the former's a
750 million dollar fortified edifice the
president's point about a quick response
underscores both the threat to US
personnel and property and the strains
of history which has seen numerous
otherwise peaceful embassy days and
nights devolve into chaos and carnage
with that fact as a stark underpinning
the president who is accused Tehran of
being fully responsible for the embassy
assault ordered about 750 soldiers
deployed to the Middle East as about
3,000 more prepared for possible
deployment in the next several days
including said defense secretary Marquez
Berg the immediate deployment of the
82nd airborne an appropriate and
precautionary action he wrote in a
statement taken in response to increase
threat levels against US personnel and
facilities we have told the Iranian
regime countless times do not confuse
president Trump's strategic patience
with weakness and unfortunately the
regime has done that which is why that
you saw the strikes over the weekend
while criticism of the president's
decisions has been relatively muted some
Democrats placed blame for the unrest in
Iraq squarely on his shoulders
Connecticut Democrat Chris Murphy
tweeting really hard to overstate how
badly Trump is bungled things in the
Middle East suggesting what the White
House is called Iran coordinated
protests are instead anti-us protests
thanks to Trump's mishandling of Iran
policy White House officials continue to
insist the protests are irani and backed
Mike and in fact they suggest there is
little evidence of growing anti
Americanism in Iraq Mike Kevin Cork
leading us off from West Palm Beach
Kevin many thanks